bonjour et merci d'être avec nous on
imagine votre colère ce matin
oui ma colère parce que tout simplement
ce que nous avons vu hier soir ce n'est
pas l'ordre républicain ce n'est pas
l'ordre public ce n'est pas la sécurité
ce n'est pas là la dignité ce n'est
surtout pas mon pays
cela fait maintenant plusieurs années
que nouveau sommes entrés dans un cycle
absolument infernal où de nombreux
réfugiés qui arrivent sur le territoire
national sont sans hébergement or
l'hébergement c'est le pilier le premier
pilier d'une politique républicaine
ensuite il faut évidemment contrôler les
personnes qui arrivent sur notre sol il
faut les orienter il faut éventuellement
les éloigner si elle devrait pour pas
aux problématiques du droit des îles
il faut les répartir et il faut les
intégrer
voilà mais ça ce sont les six piliers
d'une politique républicaine ce que nous
avons ce n'est pas la première
évacuation de camp de migrants mais
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'un
changement de ton violent hier soir mais
nommée s'éteint c'est un piège à partir
du moment où vous ne mettez pas en
classe
une politique qui permette d'accueillir
les gens en dignité c'est à dire pouvoir
se laver dormir manger en sécurité et ce
qui n'empêche pas le contrôle
bien évidemment mais dès lors que vous
ne faites pas ça vous avez des gens qui
sont en errance dans la ville et
employés la police pour les disperser
ne règle rien il épousa une dispersaient
les grands hier soir mais il aurait
surtout fallu avoir une politique
d'hébergement à partir de l'évacuation
du camp de saint denis
à partir du moment où vous laisser 500 à
600 personnes dehors eu évidemment que
ces gens vont chercher à se rassembler
ensemble et à survivre aussi aux
réactions politiques on en vient
d'entendre une qui pointe du doigt la
responsabilité des associations dans
l'organisation d'un tel d'une telle
action coup de poing comme hier mais de
toute façon l'impasse est totale
évidemment et ce sont les radicaux des
deux camps qui se frottent les mains
nous n'avons pas une politique publique
digne aujourd'hui est donc à partir de
ce moment là le piège wii se referme
c'est à dire que il y à des actions coup
de poing qui vont être mises en place
et puis la police envoyée dans ces
conditions et bien évidemment eu ses
preuves dans un certain nombre de
violences parfaitement documenté donc le
le le piège il est total ce n'est pas
comme ça que l'on peut mettre en place
une politique républicaine
mais vous savez il n'ya de cuir sourds
qui ne veut entendre
ça fait des années qu avec d'autres euh
je répète cela est donc ce qui s'est
passé hier soir était d'une certaine
manière écrit hélas merci beaucoup pour
votre réaction ce matin pierre henry
président de france fraternité